the ending is one of the most important
parts of any movie so it's no surprise
that directors have often wavered back
and forth on what tone to end their
films on even movies that would
eventually become classics almost had
significantly different endings that
were originally planned from boxing
dramas to mafia epics here are a few
movies that almost had much happier
endings Rocky Balboa
whether he wins by knockout or loses by
split decision Rocky Balboa almost
always walks away from the ring of the
smile on space as the man puts it
himself but it ain't about how hard you
hit it's about how hard you can get hit
and keep moving forward how much you can
take they keep moving forward at the end
of Rocky Balboa
the Italian stallion loses in a split
decision but wins the respect of
everyone watching the fight however
there's an alternate ending in which the
brawler bests his opponent walking away
with a razor-thin decision
is it happier yeah but it isn't Rocky my
best friend's wedding after a series of
mishaps and hijinks Julia Roberts
eventually gives up on romancing her
best friend and spends the last moments
of the movie dancing with another friend
instead
in the original ending of my best
friend's wedding Roberts finds a
potential new boyfriend at her friend's
wedding but test audiences were confused
by the sudden appearance of a new beau
hi I'm Annie Connolly test audiences
liked Rupert Everett just way too much
so II was able to make his triumphant
return in the finale who could humiliate
me aren't you you can't comment it's
just one thing stay away from Easy Rider
this seminal biker flick follows a bunch
of laid-back hippies on a cross-country
road trip right up until an incredibly
violent ending right before the credits
roll we see the bikers lying dead on the
road with their motorcycles in flames
while director Dennis Hopper originally
wanted the bikers to make it out alive
writer Terry southern told The Paris
Review that he'd convinced the director
that the dark ending was quote more or
less mandatory for Easy Rider he got a
helmet
Oh Oh I've got a helmet
why Southern wanted to write quote an
indictment of blue-collar America the
people he thought were responsible for
the Vietnam War
message received rogue one a Star Wars
story a prequel to a new hope
rogue one follows a group of resistance
fighters who are able to steal the plans
for the Death Star by sacrificing
themselves in the process however in one
of the early drafts of the screenplay
the ragtag group actually makes it out
alive director Gareth Edwards explained
to the Empire podcast and it was just
assumed by us that if we couldn't do
that there's nothing uncle s do that as
it turned out they actually could and
the result is one of the best sequences
in Star Wars history Chinatown working
for a mysterious woman named Evelyn
Mulwray
Jake get ease uncovers a massive fraud
operation in Los Angeles worse he finds
out the father of Evelyn's child has
actually no across Evelyn's twisted
father it's pretty grim stuff all capped
off by a showdown in Chinatown where
Evelyn is killed while cross steals his
daughter granddaughter get thee stands
in the middle of the street defeated as
a colleague tells him however Robert
towns original screenplay would have had
Gettys & Mulwray murder cross allowing
Evelyn and her daughter to finally
escape his grasp director Roman Polanski
and a very dark place himself due to the
recent murder of his wife rewrote an
ending where evil triumphs over good and
added the famous line to create a grim
unforgettable ending the thing when a
shape-shifting alien attacks an
Antarctic research station the crew must
band together to fight this otherworldly
foe that can look like anyone and
anything who's human and who is a thing
that's the ultimate question posed by
the things downer of a finale the film
ends with two men sharing a bottle of
whiskey freezing to death and waiting to
see who is really who editor Todd Ramsay
was so worried about the ending that he
persuaded carpenter to film the backup
just in case they had to make change
later on
according to Ramsey and just shoot an
ending that where we see that he
survives Kurt has been rescued and
seeing in a kind of small office
structure and he's just had a blood test
so that we know that he's not infected
fortunately carpenter stuck to his guns
and the thing is now recognized as a
classic largely thanks to its ultra
ambiguous ending the godfather after
rising to the top of the Mafia mountain
Michael Corleone has truly lost his way
going so far as to murder his own
brother-in-law deny it to his wife and
close himself off from her in the most
tragic door slam in cinematic history
believe it or not director Francis Ford
Coppola actually shot an alternate
ending in this deleted scene we seek a
visiting a church and lighting candles
for Michael's soul hoping there might be
a chance her husband can be redeemed but
even though the ending was closer to
Mario Puzo's novel Coppola realized he'd
already shot the perfect ending and left
it there don't give Frank oh come on you
think I make my sister a widow the fly
David Cronenberg's the fly follows Seth
Brundle a brilliant scientist who
accidentally merges his body with a fly
the movie ends with Brundle completely
mutated finally killed by his pregnant
girlfriend in a moment of tragic horror
however Cronenberg actually considered
going with several other endings one
possible ending as Veronica drifting off
to sleep and dreaming that her future
child will hatch from a chrysalis and
fly away with butterfly wings thankfully
Cronenberg realized that after the
tragic end of Brundle audiences wouldn't
be happy walking away with visions of
butterfly children and stuck to his
original ending thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]